[Music]
just when I thought I was done for the
day a Fantastic Four trailer came out
and now I have something else to talk
about the Fantastic Four movie is a
movie that a lot of people have been
crapping on for quite some time from the
revelation that dr. doom is a blogger to
the fact there's no poster there was no
trailer no official images nothing
everyone was like this movie's gonna be
horrible now I can't say who but I did
meet someone who had the opportunity to
see a rough cut of the film and said
individual was somewhat impressed with
what he saw and so even though I was
kind of skeptical I was like okay Plus
josh trank made a pretty damn good movie
with Chronicle which I really enjoyed
and actually bought the blu-ray was just
saying something and I'm a big fan of
the cast of this movie I mean miles
teller whiplash the spectacular now
Michael B Jordan Fruitvale station this
film is filled with very talented people
and directed by someone who is equally
as talented still the other two
fantastic four movies horrible but this
trailer has given me some hope now
similar to the ant-man trailer I was not
blown away by this teaser what it has
shown to me though is that it is filmed
and shocked beautifully all of the shots
on display in this movie even the ones
where it's just people talking or a
close-up of miles teller they all look
gorgeous this is a gorgeous looking
movie already and if the tone on display
in the trailer is equal to the tone
we're gonna get in the film then we are
most definitely not getting a comedy
heavy spoof movie like the other two
which is great I mean hopefully this is
gonna be the Batman Begins for the
Fantastic Four and the last two are just
like the Schumacher Batman's there's a
voiceover I'm not sure who this is it
could be Doctor Doom maybe I'm wrong it
could be someone else but the voice-over
is very well done it gives you a very
interesting vibe and what I like about
this movie not just the look is the fact
that it does actually seem like it's a
serious movie now sometimes people are
saying lately this complaint that all
superior movies had to be serious
superhero movies need to be fun that's
great the first Avengers is really fun
guardians of the galaxy was very fun
ant-man
looks like it's really fun so we are
still getting fun superhero films and
it's nice to see a more serious tone
Fantastic Four film because the last two
were basically comedies face it I mean
they may have been unintentional
comedies but they for companies
nonetheless and we're not even gonna
talk about the 90s Fantastic Four movie
oh my god my point being is that despite
not seeing very much in this trailer I
do have some faith restored I'm very
curious to see how some of these guys
look doing their superhero wee stuff
because in this trailer you don't see
very much of that there are tiny hints
you see the Human Torch light up a
couple times you see the backs of them
and thing looks ok it looks fine but you
don't really see that much I'm curious
to see how they handle that how much of
its gonna be motion capture there's
gonna be a suit I know there will be
some prosthetics and stuff I just want
to see how they handle all that I am
very curious to see how they take these
characters since they're all very young
because in a lot of the comics mr.
fantastic has gray hair right here so
I'm very curious to see this more young
take on it it looks beautiful the shots
are fantastic I have total faith in Josh
Trank as a director I'm just really
hoping the script delivers that the CGI
delivers and that it's not a cheesy fest
of idiocy but this trailer does give me
some hope and I am more excited about it
now what are your guys thoughts on the
new Fantastic Four trailer and where
it's going as always thank you so much
for watching guys and if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
mine eyes
[Music]